dans un premier temps je reviens sur
votre sondage qui est extrêmement
intéressant ou 80 euros
d'après ce sondage 83% des français
choisiraient joe biden plutôt que donald
trump et c'est très révélateur en fait
je pense d'une énorme naïveté de la part
des français et plus généralement des
européens puisque tous les européens je
crois à l'exception de quelques pays
d'europe centrale sont dans les mêmes
proportions
je pense que beaucoup d'européens et en
partie et les dirigeants européens
pensent que donald trump sera une
parenthèse est qu après donald trump
on va se retrouver papa états unis
qu'yvan pas ternes et une protégée
or et rétablir le parapluie nucléaire et
que tout sera bien merveilleux comme
avant et je pense que c'est une énorme
erreur
d'abord parce que on va parler politique
étrangère mais la politique étrangère a
commencé à basculer la politique
étrangère américaine a commencé à
basculer vers l'extrême orient et à se
désengager de l'europe avant donald
trump
c'est barack obama déjà qui décide de
qui qui conceptualise une certaine
manière à sa façon le fait de tourner
les yeux des etats-unis et l'intérêt des
états unis versent qui se verra ce qui
se passe en chine
que ce soit dans la compétition
économique ou même dans le rapport de
force quasi militaire donc donald trump
ne fait que suivre un mouvement ils
l'amplifient il va beaucoup plus loin un
particulière remettant en cause les les
les relations multilatérales mais le le
le
le paquebot america avait déjà commencé
à changer de cap avant donald trump et
c'est une vraie à mon avis naïveté de
penser que si donald trump est battu
cette nuit et bien tout redeviendra
comme avant mais je pense que ceci
explique aussi la le sondage est la
grande naïveté des européens
deuxièmement sur la politique étrangère
alors pour être tout à fait honnête
comme toujours il ya du bon et du moins
bon le mauvais pour commencer c'est
qu'effectivement il a
chercher à désengager les états unis
d'un certain nombre d'institutions
multilatérales
il a il a remis les états unis dans ce
qui était en fait la philosophie
profonde du pays durant tout le 19e
siècle
sirvent gros jusqu'à la première guerre
mondiale les états unis sont un pays
isolationniste c'est un pays qui ne
veulent pas s'occuper des affaires du
monde qui met en place la doctrine
monroe qui consiste à dire aux européens
vous rester en dehors du champ des
amériques et vous nous laissez notre
chasse gardée en particulier en amérique
latine et et nous on se gardera mettra
en place une neutralité en particulier
entre les britanniques et les français
donc ça il ya un retour au 19e siècle à
l'amérique jacksonienne qui est assez
remarquable et qu'on avait perdu de vue
parce que l'amérique est différente
depuis la fin de la première guerre
mondiale est bien entendu surtout depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
dans un deuxième temps ce qui est quand
même à noter c'est que il à donald trump
a honnêtement tenter de trouver des
liens des liens affectifs en particulier
avec kim jong-un en corée du nord pour
faire baisser la tension
il a remporté un certain nombre de
succès absolument incontestable au
moyen-orient en particulier dans la paix
entre les israéliens et un certain
nombre d'alliés américain sunnite
et puis vis-à-vis de la russie c'est
peut-être la première fois depuis depuis
là le début de la guerre froide la
russie n'a pas véritablement constituée
avec donald trump un enjeu majeur ça
n'était pas une obsession
l'obsession était beaucoup plus la chine
l'iran que la russie c'est la première
fois depuis 1946 47 que les états unis
avaient un regard plutôt détaché sur la
question grecque ce qui a permis sans
doute aussi de faire baisser la tension
je rappelle les propos extrêmement dur
que hillary clinton tenait en 2016 au
moment de la campagne électorale et que
joe biden reprend parce que c'est
vraiment la doctrine démocrate
donc si vous voulez pour concours conclu
on a comme toujours un bilan avec du bon
et du moins bon mais il serait
extrêmement réducteur de limiter la
politique de donald trump à ses coups de
menton et à sa personnalité et là je
rejoins paul sire que ce qu'il ya
derrière est beaucoup plus intéressant
après on peut critiquer mais c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant et surtout
c'est une durée longue qui ne se limite
pas à ce qui a commandé ce qui aurait
commencé en 2016
ça a commencé bien avant